welcome back to the program remember
that the number one way to support this
show
is by getting a membership at
joinedpakman.com if you've been looking
at it very strongly or even not
this is a great time to do it go to
joinpakman.com
choose any membership you like monthly
or yearly if the price looks good
do it if you want a little bit of a
discount how about
66 off with the coupon code
2020 now that is all one word all
lowercase two zero
two zero now you will save 66
let's pick up on some i guess we're
still calling them calls even though
this week they're from the david pakman
show
discord let's see who wants to check
in today let's go to chris from texas
chris from texas you were on what is on
your mind today my friend
hey hey david can you hear me i can hear
you perfectly
all right i called you about a couple of
months ago and i wanted to say
uh thank you for like teaching me how to
think more critically like
i remember thinking how i could thought
that biden was not gonna be able to win
yeah but looking at the polls from 538
it looks like it's pretty much
over for trump at this point i mean
biden would have
i don't have to literally about have to
die in order for
trump to win right now well listen i
hope that you are right
but all we need to do is just vote right
we ultimately have no control over
anything
other than whether we vote so i i love
the optimism the polls look
ugly right now but we just don't know
in the 25 days that are left we just
don't know so i share your
cautious optimism let's focus on the
cautious and let's make sure we vote
yeah i understand i'm gonna vote i'm
gonna vote next week's
uh tuesday as well beautiful
also so also i'm wondering too now like
with two of the
senate members testing positive for
coronavirus three in fact
oh three three now yeah well it's mike
lee
uh tom tillis and ron johnson yeah so
do you think it's possible that amy
comey's however you pronounce her name
amy coney barrett's nomination will be
delayed now
i i do think that there is a good chance
that it doesn't happen before
election day but if republicans are
determined i don't see any way
that it won't happen during the period
between the election and the
inauguration
my only hope is if the coronavirus
positives
prevent the vote from happening before
november 3rd
and then joe biden wins and democrats
take the senate and the martha mcsally
seat is immediately seated because
remember that's a special election so
mark if mark kelly wins he might be
seated right away
i'm hoping that there would be such
outrage
if republicans still try to push it
through i'm talking outrage to the point
of mass rallies and i don't know if that
will happen
that would be the dream scenario that
republicans abandon
the nomination it's very optimistic it's
very
uphill but i think it's the only chance
we've got
also i'm kind of worried about packing
the courts as well i thought i know
people say that they want to pack the
courts just because
they want to at least be able to get
progressive reform yeah but i'm worried
that it could be used against us in the
future for republicans to pack the court
as well
it certainly could but here's here's
what i would say uh
here's what i would say to that chris
joe biden has has
not answered whether he would or
wouldn't be in favor of that
and i think he's been smart not to
answer it for now because it would
whatever he answers will become the
focus and it's not really what this is
about
if you look back at joe biden's history
my reading of it is that he's unlikely
to pack the court so i actually if
you're concerned about that i don't
actually think biden will do it
okay my last question is what do you
think we should do
if joe biden becomes president should we
try to push him to for more left-wing
policies or should we just
try to undo all of the damage trump has
done first well it's both it's not one
or the other i mean a lot of
the damage trump has done can be undone
via executive order executive orders
and at the same time particularly if
democrats take the senate then you've
got
big legislative accomplishments that we
can start working on so you got to do
both
yeah all right thank you for the time
david chris i appreciate it so much
chris from texas great to hear
uh from chris from texas one of our
sponsors today
is monk pack keto granola bars and they
are giving you 20
off when you go to davidpakman.com
snack and use the coupon code pacman you
know a lot of these
uh low-carb snack bars have a reputation
for not tasting great
but i can tell you from trying these
myself that that is not the case with
the monk pack
keto granola bars they taste just as
good
if not better than the sugar-filled
chewy granola bars that many of us
love but these contain only one gram of
sugar
two net carbs only 140 calories they're
completely plant-based and gluten-free
great for anybody following a low-carb
diet
but also perfect for anybody like me
who's just trying to
reduce sugar intake which i think is a
good thing i've been working
on a box of these at home they're
delicious soft chewy texture
bunch of great flavors including peanut
butter coconut cocoa
chip which is my personal favorite it's
great for a quick breakfast
a snack in the afternoon i have been
loving these
you can get to their website by going to
davidpakman.com
snack the link is under this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman